[Music]
foreign
so in the last lecture we derived well
we didn't derive we wrote down the
second order and fourth order runga
integration schemes to integrate a
vector field x dot equals f of x comma T
and we essentially walked through how
these algorithms work in terms of taking
you know half Euler steps in a direction
and querying your vector field and then
coming up with better estimates to step
your system forward and in particular
what we found is that the runka cut a
fourth order scheme is way way more
accurate than second order rangakatta
and then forward and backward Euler so
in particular the rk4 algorithm is kind
of the Workhorse numerical integration
algorithm most of the time that you're
going to be integrating differential
equations you're going to want to start
with an rk4 unless you have something
stochastic highly highly chaotic or very
very stiff in which case you might use
another custom integrator but for kind
of General integration rk4 is great and
one of the best things about it is that
every time step the error kind of the
local error of this update scheme is
order delta T to the fifth power which
is really really good so that means that
if I make delta T
you know 10 times smaller this local
error gets 10 to the fifth times smaller
it gets a hundred thousand times smaller
which is really really really good
and so what I'm going to do today
is I'm actually going to code up from
scratch this fourth order runga Cutta
scheme so this is again built into
python to Matlab in Matlab this is
called ode
45ode45
you know so you don't technically have
to code up your own but I thought it'd
be fun and illustrative just to show you
how to actually code this up it's very
very simple it's just you know these
literally these five lines of Matlab or
python code and then we're going to use
this to integrate a chaotic differential
equation one of my favorites which I'll
write down here which is the Lorenz 1963
lorentz
1963 model which is a section
essentially uh x dot
equals Sigma times y minus X
y dot equals x times this rho minus Z
minus y I'll tell you what you know
Sigma rho and beta are in a minute and Z
dot equals x y
minus beta Z we're going to do this for
constants Sigma
beta and rho
equal to 10 8 3 and 28. these are kind
of the standard parameters that people
usually use for the lorentz 1963 problem
and so this is a really really simple
differential equation it's one of the
most popular chaotic differential
equations ever lorentz introduced it in
1963 to model the chaotic thermal
convection observed in the atmosphere so
over the cycle of day and night as the
Earth gets heated and the ground gets
heated and the air gets heated it
creates these large convection cells if
any of you have ever been to you know
Arizona or New Mexico or west Texas
you'll have seen evidence of these
massive
convection cells which can go chaotic
and this is like the simplest
mathematical model that captures that
chaotic behavior and it's barely even
non-linear so it technically is
non-linear because of these two terms x
y That's non-linear and this x z all of
the other terms are are linear so it's a
very simple different differential
equation and sigma rho and beta are just
constants they're numbers that you tune
to get the right kind of chaotic
Behavior to match your system
so this is what we're going to
we're going to code up this rk4 we're
going for a single time step and we're
going to use that to build a trajectory
and then we're going to simulate this
interesting chaotic 1963 lorentz system
um
and I'm going to do this in uh
Python and Matlab one last thing I'll
point out is that the Lawrence 1963
you've almost certainly seen these
simulations before the chaotic butterfly
attractor so you know the Lorenz 1963 is
the system that gives you this kind of
cool butterfly attractor that you've
almost certainly seen before
and in you know like popular movies and
stuff you've heard of the butterfly
effect that if a butterfly flaps its
wings
um
in Texas you might have
um you know a hurricane somewhere else
in in the world you know somewhere way
way far away so a small small small
change to the initial conditions of this
chaotic system can lead to hugely
different effects uh in in future time
now the butterfly effect is is massively
uh misunderstood
um so I'm not you know actually claiming
that if a butterfly flaps its wings
somewhere in the world you'll get a you
know tsunami wave in another part that's
silly and actually in a couple of
lectures I'll have a whole lecture and
then ultimately a sequence of lectures
on chaotic systems like this where we
can really start to dig into what it
actually means to be chaotic and have
this sensitive dependence on initial
conditions but
um you know weather is chaotic uh
climate and whether you know our chaotic
phenomena and this is one simple novel
for that so we're going to code this up
we're going to simulate this system I'm
probably going to start in in Matlab
just because it's so easy to do these
operations and make this there's a lot
less overhead and then I'm going to do
it in Python so if you want python just
jump to that chapter marker in the video
if you want Matlab jump to that one
that's going to start right now
okay good
so let's get going
here
okay so good it looks like I have my
Matlab up first and I actually have
pre-written all of these scripts you can
download these uh you know dot m or
Jupiter notebook files and the links
will be below but I think I'm actually
going to cook up
um at least in Matlab some of these
algorithms from scratch because I think
this is going to be really kind of
helpful for you so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to create a function that
given XK and this function f of x comma
T it's going to spit out the fourth
order runga approximation of the next
time step
and
um
this is a little bit of a mess in Matlab
I always think of my differential
equation as x dot equals f of x comma T
in Matlab this is confusing in Matlab
it's x dot equals F of T comma X okay so
this is just a convention you're going
to need to remember and I'm going to
need to remember and I always forget I
wrote this down assuming that my my
Vector field f is a function of space
and time the Matlab convention is that
it's expecting a function of time comma
space silly I know but that's what it is
so that's what I'm going to do here
really easy we're just going to swap
every time you see a t and an X you're
just going to switch their order no big
deal okay so I'm going to create this
function and and it's going to spit out
the output
um you know my X output and I'm going to
call my function rk4 single step because
it's going to take a single delta T time
step
and it's going to have to take some
arguments so this rk4 single time step
it's going to have to have this right
hand side function my function it's
going to need to take a delta T it's
going to need to know what DT is so it's
going to take an argument DT it's going
to need to know what the initial time is
for example what is the base time I'm
going to call that t
okay
and then it's also going to need to know
what is my initial position uh comma XK
and so X Out is really x k plus one okay
the output of this is X K plus 1 and the
input is x k t k delta T and the right
hand side function f of T comma X
the this is just Matlab for I'm building
a function called rk4 single step
and then that function is super simple
I'm literally going to Define F1 then F2
then F3 then F4 and then I'm going to
return this expression here so I'm going
to build F1 then I'm going to build F2
then F3 then F4 and then X Out is going
to equal
uh my you know my XK
Plus
DT over 6
times F1 plus 2 F2 plus 2 F3 plus F4
that's it okay so it's literally this
simple uh once I haven't written these
down yet I'm going to Define them in a
minute but it's messy so I'm going to
Define these and then I'm going to
literally add them up in this formula to
get x k Plus 1. and F1 I mean I could
probably read this off without even
looking at the board because we can
argue in our minds through what is
happening here F1 we are querying our
Vector field F of T comma X
at tkxk tkxk
F2 we take a half Euler step in the F1
Direction and query that Vector field so
F of T K plus DT over 2 x k plus d t
over 2 times F1
so that's a half Euler step in the F1
Direction and then I query my Vector
field in that direction
um F3 is exactly the same thing except
now I'm taking a half step in the F2
Direction so I'm just going to copy all
of that and replace this with F2 and
then F4 is I'm taking a I'm querying my
Vector field f after taking a full Euler
step in the F3 Direction so F of T K
plus DT comma x k plus DT times F3
and I'm pretty sure that's it that is
how easy it is to cook up your own
Kick-Ass runga cut a fourth order
integration scheme this is so much more
accurate than a forward Oiler please
don't use forward Oiler use run Dakota
it's way way more accurate and it's
super duper easy okay so
um this is it that's all there is here
okay I'm going to save this and Matlab
is going to try to convince me
to save this as something called rk4
single step sorry that's so tiny I'm
just going to call this underscore new
so I don't mess up my old code which is
definitely using a slightly different
notation and that's it that's rk4 single
step
the other only thing I need to do is
Define this lorentz dot m which is going
to be the right hand side of this
differential equation x dot equals F of
um so so
lorentz
sometimes in my notes I use x dot equals
f of x sometimes in my note I use y dot
equals F of Y here I guess I'm using Y
naught equals F of Y to Define lorentz
it doesn't matter this is just a vector
that contains X Y and Z sorry x dot y
dot Z dot is d y
and Lorenz again it's expecting a
function of T comma space time comma
whatever my variable is in this case
I've called it y instead of X for some
reason
um I'm gonna change it because like why
wouldn't why would I not call this DX
and X
and x and x
sorry to be confusing here no reason
I I trust that you all feel comfortable
with me changing the names of x's to y's
it doesn't matter but just to be
consistent here I've called everything
else X for the entire lecture so DX is x
dot uh it we're expecting a function
Matlab is expecting ode45 is expecting
and my rk4 single step is expecting a
function of T comma X so it's a function
of T comma X and then I give in these
extra parameters Sigma beta rho which
I'm going to lock into place when I
simulate this so once I lock those into
place this is going to look like a
function of T comma X for my integrator
and then this lorentz right hand side
the right hand side of my Vector field
is literally going to be this DX it's
going to have three components one for x
dot y Dot and Z dot in lines four five
and six and so x dot is Sigma of you
know X2 is X is a vector X1 X2 X3 is x y
z so this is y minus X uh this is x
times rho minus Z minus y and this is x
times y minus beta Z so you can read
that off kind of the same as here I'm
using index notation because I want to
be passing this thing vectors I don't
want to be having to keep track of
little x's and y's and Z's I'm just
going to spin in a vector of x y z
that's what I'm calling kind of bold X
here and I'm going to return a vector of
DX's which are you know x dot y dot Z
dot you should feel pretty comfortable
with you know my crazy notation at this
point so that's it we have lorentz we
have
um
rk4 single step and so now I can go to
my lecture 18 underscore similar Lorenz
that's what I've called it it might be
called something different in your
um
description below and so it's pretty
simple to do this what we're going to do
is we're going to Define our lorentz
parameters these are chosen by lorentz
to make the system interesting and
chaotic so Sigma 10 beta 8 thirds row
28. we're going to pick an initial
condition and here again I've changed
everything from X's to from y's which I
think is confusing so I'm just going to
go back to you know this is X naught
uh yep
and I'm going to change this to Big X
I'll I'll change all of my x's to y's in
a minute well we're going to go line by
line so I'm picking an initial condition
X naught as minus 8 8 27 so that means
uh X naught equals minus eight y naught
equals eight and Z naught equals 27.
I'm span that I'm going to integrate
over so I'm going to use a delta T of
0.01 which for a fifth order accurate
scheme is going to be super duper small
local errors and I'm going to integrate
from times 0 to time 4. uh and so now
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
build this big for Loop here that's
going to take each each step of this for
Loop is going to take my runga cut a
four single step one time step forward
and before I butcher this code I'm going
to change all of my uh X's
to wise
sorry all of my y's to X's so I don't
completely confuse myself
uh immediately
almost done almost done almost done
almost done okay well that's at least
good for now so um and now what I'm
going to do because I don't just want to
so I'm going to start with X not my
initial condition uh here and I'm going
to do this for Loop 4i in you know my
time span divided by DT for as many DTS
as fit in this time span
um
I'm going to take my runga cut a single
step so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to take my runga cuddle a single
step
starting at this x input equals x naught
this is kind of x k and X Out is X K
plus 1. so X in is a is x k x out is X K
plus one and what I'm going to do is I'm
going to initialize my input x k to be
my initial condition
it's my argument here so at every step
I'm going to be evaluating my runga kind
of fourth order starting at this base
point x in
that's going to give me this point x out
and then at the end of this step I'm
going to you know my new X in for the
next time step is going to be this XK
plus 1 so then x k plus 1 is going to
get plugged in and I'm going to get x k
plus 2 then at the end of that time step
x k plus 2 is going to become my input
and I'll get x k plus 3 as X out and
this will step my trajectory forward in
time and so I'm creating this big kind
of array big X and that's going to hold
my whole trajectory because I want to
keep track of all of these intermediate
X1 X2 X3 x 4 x k x k plus 1 x k plus 2.
I want to keep track of those in this
big array X uh this big array X here and
this is kind
of kind way to do it I'm literally just
appending my output as a new column on
this big X Matrix every time step very
inefficient this basically means Matlab
is reallocating a new array every single
time step which is stupid
but you know this is so fast and I just
wanted to be quick and dirty it's fine
if you wanted to do this fast what you
would do is you would pre-allocate this
big X array make it full of zeros and
then you would just you know overwrite
those zeros with the current part of the
trajectory
and then once we're done we can plot the
trajectory and we'll get something like
this butterfly there's some Matlab code
here you know just to make my my fonts
look nice and I'm changing the Viewpoint
so that it's at a nice angle
and then finally I'm going to compare
with built in RK for adaptive step
and here I'm also going to change these
to x's and I hope that doesn't mess
anything up that's an X and this is X
naught good and so the built-in Matlab
code ode45 is a really really slick code
so it is a built-in rk4 scheme but it's
actually a little bit better than mine
because it takes an Adaptive time step
so if it sees the error the local error
creeping up it has an internal estimate
of that when it sees that local error
creeping up it's going to cut its delta
T in half until it keeps that error
bounded to a certain threshold tolerance
so this is actually a really really nice
code also if the error is not big it
might make the delta T bigger so that
it'll run faster and it's going to take
you see almost exactly the same
arguments here it's taking in Lorenz of
T comma X blah blah blah blah it knows
what time span is and what the initial
condition is and it's going to integrate
the whole trajectory all at once
so mine because I developed mine as a
single step you know one delta T time
stepper I had to write a for Loop to
generate my trajectory
ode45 will build the whole trajectory
for you you just tell it the whole time
span you want to simulate so that's also
nice it's one line instead of a big for
Loop
what other things do I want to show you
I messed up my view here that needs an
outer parenthesis
um
again
matlabs od45
and my rk4 single step is expecting the
the function the ode function here to be
a function just of T comma X and so the
way we take a function that has more
variables lorentz actually had T comma X
comma Sigma comma beta comma rho it had
five input variables if I want to turn
that into a function of T comma this
would be T comma X
if I want to turn that into a function
of T comma x what I do is I do this at T
comma X and it tells Matlab I'm creating
a function on the Fly that only has
those two input variables and it's going
to be lorentz of that t comma X where I
lock in Sigma beta and rho because
you'll remember up here I defined Sigma
beta rho so those are actual numbers
and so this at T comma X of lorentz T
comma X comma Sigma beta rho what that
does is that returns to Matlab a
function right there of just of T comma
X where we've locked in the numbers
Sigma beta rho into those three Slots of
my function
and so this is a way I'm same thing in
RK for a single step I've created just a
function of T comma X because that's
what it's expecting uh in fact if you go
back up here
you'll remember that um
my function uh fun this should be fun
this should be not F this should be fun
function
that function it's expecting a function
just of T comma X and so if it had you
know five arguments this code would
crash because I've only given it two
inputs right here so this needs to be a
function of just two inputs and since my
lorentz function
is a function of five inputs I have to
lock into place three numbers here to
force it into being a function of only
two variables T comma X that's how that
works in Matlab
um that was a little fast this is called
a function handle if you want to Google
function Handles in Matlab especially
for integration you can you can find
this I'm pretty sure somewhere on my
channel I have a little five minute
video on function Handles in Matlab back
in my undergrad class I used to teach 10
years ago but this should run I think I
don't have any errors and this is going
to run I've got a good feeling about it
oh my goodness it ran
and I believe white here is my delta T
uh rk4 single step and I think red is
the built-in ode45 Matlab code and you
can see this actually has that butterfly
attractor that I told you about so you
can see the two wings of the butterfly
super cool and you can also see that the
white and the red curves almost
perfectly lie on top of each other they
should they're the same algorithm right
like built-in matlabs od45 is an rk4
scheme but remember ode45 might be a
little bit more accurate than mine
because it can actually take an Adaptive
time step if it needs whereas mine is a
fixed time step so the red curve might
be a little more accurate potentially
but there you can see they're almost
identical almost the same
super cool so we can simulate chaotic
systems now really nasty systems super
gnarly systems systems where X is a
vector of three states or five states or
a hundred States
functions that vary in time this Vector
field could change in time and we can
simulate that all with this fourth order
runga Kata scheme really really cool
really really easy
um I can't do this
live because my fonts are too small here
and there's no way of changing the comet
3 line width in Matlab but if you're at
home and you're coding along you should
take this output of ode45 which outputs
it outputs the time vector and the
trajectory Matrix X and you can write
this comment three
so just like our plotting command plot 3
plotted the first second and third
components of our trajectory comet3 does
the same thing but it gives you this
cool little Tracer so it looks like a
little animation of the trajectory being
built so you should try that it looks
really really cool
okay that's everything I wanted to show
you on the Matlab version of this runga
Kata scheme we can cook up our own we
can use the built-in they give us the
same output
usually you should use the built-in
ode45 I just showed you this because I
thought it was cool and I thought you
should know what's under the hood this
od45 is probably better than my rk4
single step in almost every way so most
of the time you should use od45
but occasionally actually in the next
lecture I'll show you occasionally we do
want to do this kind of single step
algorithm the way that I cooked it up in
particular if I want to run through a
huge bundle of trajectories a bunch of
initial conditions all at once like a
big cube of initial conditions it's
going to be very slow to write a big
nested for loop around ode45 one for
each of those initial conditions whereas
with my rk4 single step I can plug in a
big bundle of initial conditions and run
them all at once using vectorized
algebra so that'll be much more
efficient using my code that might be
the only case where you'll want to use
this instead of this but I'll show you
that in the next lecture
okay I'm going to switch to python now
um maybe you'll find it interesting if
you want to Learn Python but if not you
can skip this
okay good so we are going to simulate
the Lorenz system in Python now and we
are going to use our we're going to
write our own
rk4 time stepper using this fourth order
runga cut a scheme I showed you earlier
and we're going to compare that to the
built-in fourth order runga cutter
scheme that's kind of built into python
okay I'm not going to write this from
scratch this is pre-written code but you
can download this and follow along in
this Jupiter notebook this was written
by Alan captainaglu based on my Matlab
code so we're going to walk through this
we're going to use the scipy integrator
the solve ivp which has a fourth order
ode integrator built into it and so
we're also going to lock in the lorentz
parameters Sigma beta row these are the
ones that lorentz chose to be
interesting and chaotic so we're just
going to use those
and what I really want to show you here
is how easy it is to write this the
single step RK integrator so what I'm
going to do is write a function that
given some initial condition some you
know XK or some YK or some y naught it's
going to spit out the next time step on
the trajectory okay
um
a couple of things in Matlab and in
Python they're built-in integrators are
expecting a function of T comma X for
the right hand side not a function of X
comma T so I always write my
differential equation x dot equals f of
x or x dot equals f of x comma T I think
that makes a lot of sense
and Matlab are expecting the right hand
side Vector field to be a function of T
comma X that's a little confusing but
it's it's not that big of a deal what it
means is that your function your right
hand side function here that you're
defining as the input to this rk4
integrator it's just going to be a
function of T comma y so anytime you see
X or or t comma X anytime you see x t
here you just flip them in this code and
everything will be fine and also I
believe usually I write x dot equals f
of x here I'm writing y dot equals F of
Y nothing should change here I want you
to be really flexible and okay changing
the names of things this could be you
know why not dummy for all I care or it
could be you know it doesn't matter what
I call this it could be y dummy dot
equals F of T comma y dummy and it's
still a differential equation that we
know how to solve so here my
differential equation is in a variable y
you know y dot equals F of T comma Y and
this function this right hand side
function f instead of being a y comma T
it's of T comma y okay you'll have to
come to terms with that
um
good
and then the last thing I want to point
out is that you know this was a
differential equation
a vector that I'm calling uh that I'm
calling y here so so this Y in this code
is actually a vector of States
um you know for x and y and z
good and so given some initial input
Point why not what we're going to do is
literally we're going to build F1 we're
going to query our Vector field function
at time naught and why not at our base
Point let's call this you know TK and y
k it's whatever my starting point is for
this step
then given that F1 I'm going to take a
half Euler step in the F1 Direction and
evaluate the vector field to get F2
then I'm going to do the exact same
thing same thing to get F3 taking a half
Euler step but now in the F2 Direction
and then finally for F4 I'm going to
take a full Euler step in the F3
direction to get F4 and then I add those
up in this combination those F's I add
those to my base Point here it's an x k
plus one here it's y naught it's
whatever my my my starting point is for
this delta T step and it'll spit out the
output y out which is my my K plus month
my next time step in the trajectory so
really really simple it's essentially
just these five lines of code to do this
uh the single step integrator that's a
function
similarly what we're doing is defining
this lorentz
1963 Vector field which again python is
expecting uh you know it's it's ode
integrator is expecting a function of T
comma X or t comma Y in this case and so
again this d y is a vector of
derivatives x dot y dot Z dot so d y has
a first this first row is x dot the next
row is y Dot and the third row is z Dot
and so you can read this off because Y
is a vector of X Y and Z this is you
know y minus X this is x times rho minus
Z minus y and this is x times y minus
beta Z that's how you read this off and
that would be the x dot the x dot the Y
Dot and the Z dot terms of this
differential equation
and that's it so that's uh defining this
right hand side Vector field
um for whatever constant Sigma rho and
beta we've defined up above I believe
we've already defined those let's just
double check
um
good I guess these are kind of like
Global parameters for those functions
uh
can actually run this system and
integrate it forward so we're going to
start with some initial condition my
kind of Y naught Vector is
-8 in the X Direction plus eight in the
y direction and plus 27 in the Z
Direction that's my initial condition
and then we're going to integrate that
system forward in time we're going to
use a delta T of 0.01 which is going to
be really good because this is such an
accurate scheme that's a that's a small
enough delta T and we're going to
integrate from Time Zero to time Big T
equals 10. okay and you know how to do
this we create a Lin space we use Lin
space to create a Time Vector we're
going to store this trajectory in this
Big Y here so um
because this is a single step integrator
it only takes you know XK and walks it
forward to XK plus one and then so on
and so forth we're going to have to
store those intermediate you know xks if
we want to plot our trajectory we're
going to need to store those in a big
array called Y where the First Column of
that array is going to be my initial
condition and then each subsequent
column is going to be my next step
through this RK for single step
integrator
we're going to write a big for Loop and
for every delta T we're going to apply a
we're going to step it forward or our
state and so we're going to start with
our input y being y naught and it's
going to give us an output Y which is y1
and then at the end of this for Loop the
input for the next step is going to be
the output of this step so y1 becomes
the input to the next time step and then
it'll spit out Y2 and then that y output
becomes the Y input for the next step so
then we input Y2 and we get Y3 and so on
and so forth and so forth and in each
step we append that new part of the
trajectory to this big Matrix Y which is
holding our whole trajectory
that's it again writing this uh to step
our trajectory forward is just a for
Loop
and then we can plot our trajectory
um you know we can plot the X versus Y
versus Z trajectory and get this cool
you know three-dimensional plot that you
see here
um good and then we're going to compare
that that was ours we wrote this from
scratch I wanted to show you how it
works we're going to compare that from
scratch with this solve ivp built in
Python integrator which is essentially
going to be its own built-in rk4
integrator and I'm pretty sure this is
not the only one there's there's other
rk4 integrators in Python you can Google
this and find other ones this is the one
that Alan used and again it takes in the
input the lorentz vector field it's
going to integrate on this time span
from this initial condition
and then we can plot that for comparison
pretty easy I should have pointed out
this that this rk4 single step takes in
as inputs the lorentz right-hand side
Vector field which is some right hand
side function of T comma X or in this
case T comma y it takes in the DT it
needs to know what delta T is it takes
in uh the current time and the current y
State and it'll give us the next y State
a k Plus 1.
okay so if we
this hopefully there's no errors I'm
just going to run it all from scratch
just to show you that there's no magic
happening
okay running it running it running it
and this is our output
um and so
I'm inverting my colors so I actually
think blue is yellow and red is cyan
um so so
my integrator is the yellow one and
Python's built-in integrator
is this the blue or the cyan one and
you'll notice that they're almost
perfectly on top of each other they give
the same thing and that's very
reassuring because they are built on the
same algorithm they're both using an rk4
integrator if I had to guess they are
tiny tiny tiny bit different you can see
they eventually after a while start to
become a little bit different that's
because this is a chaotic system and so
even tiny tiny changes in anything in
the algorithm will cause them to
eventually be a little bit different and
specifically I think that the solve ivp
algorithm is almost certainly using an
Adaptive time step meaning it has its
own estimate of the local the local
error and if it thinks it's getting too
high it'll actually cut the delta T in
half
to keep that error bounded and similarly
if it thinks its error is under control
it might actually double the DT to make
it run faster so solve ivp is a really
slick code you should use this one in
general and not the one we wrote right
here unless you need it I just did this
because I wanted to show you how to code
this up yourself to show you what was
under the hood of this this nice general
purpose integrator that you're using
um
good and it's rare that you would
actually want to use write your own
instead of doing this one case that you
might want to write your own is if I
want to run a huge bundle of
trajectories through this differential
equation all at once it's actually very
slow in Python and also in Matlab to
write a big for Loop to go through all
of those trajectories because these are
not compiled codes these are interpreted
codes that have to kind of compile on
the Fly and so writing these big for
Loops one for each initial condition is
is going to be super slow here but our
single step integrator actually we can
take in as an argument a huge bundle of
initial conditions and step all of those
one DT forward in time and this will be
a lot more efficient because this is
using what's known as a vectorized
operation which is relying on kind of
deep buried compiled Fortran code
written decades ago that's much much
faster than writing a big for Loop to go
through those trajectories that's like
the only case I can think of where you'd
actually want to use your own instead of
this built-in
uh python code here so
um you know pretty good code to use
okay good that's kind of what I wanted
to show you with rk4 is how to cook it
up yourself in Matlab and python how to
run and compare it on this chaotic
system with the built-in integrators and
I will point out you know I showed you
rk2 and rk4 so you're probably wondering
yourself well are there higher order
schemes the answer is absolutely there
is an rk78
rangakata felberg actually rkf78 it's an
amazing integrator it's super gnarly but
it's one of the most accurate
integrators and it's actually really
good for chaotic systems like planetary
Dynamics and double pendula and you know
chaotic hamiltonian systems it tends to
be really good and there's a whole
family there's infinitely many rangakata
schemes you could cook up depending on
your needs if you wanted to this is kind
of the the all-purpose version for most
daily scientific Computing use
okay
um in the next lecture maybe I'll show
you how to do those vectorized
Integrations I was talking about to run
a huge cube of initial conditions
through your your simulation because I
think that's kind of cool to see
um thank you for paying attention
[Music]